in this lesson we're going to be talking
about why our airplane has a left
turning tendency
in case you weren't already aware when
our airplanes at high angles of attack
high power settings and low airspeed for
some reason the airplane wants to turn
left
because of this when we take off or when
we meet these conditions
you'll find that you need to put right
rudder pressure in to fix the problem
let's look at a few reasons for that the
first reason for this is torque reaction
from the engine
and the propeller to understand this we
need to look at newton's third law of
physics
for every action there's an equal and
opposite reaction
now obviously you know that the
propeller and the inside parts of the
engine need to turn
in order to create thrust but you might
not have considered that
reaction that affects our airplane so
our propeller turns one direction
that's our action then our airplane's
reaction
is to roll to the left one important
thing to remember about torque reaction
is that the more power you put in
the bigger that reaction is going to be
because of that
torque reaction is strongest at high
power settings
you'll want to remember that a lot of
times manufacturers will design the
airplane
so that you won't notice torque reaction
during cruise
most older airplanes are designed so
that that left wing creates more lift
when you're at the perfect cruising
speed
because of this if we slow the airplane
down below cruising speed
fork reaction will come back into play
on newer airplanes they often offset the
engine to counteract that torque
reaction with weight
instead this will help alleviate some of
the torque reaction at low air speeds
but not all of it
the biggest things for you to remember
about torque reaction today is that it's
most powerful
at high power settings low air speeds
and high angles of attack
now let's take a quick look at p factor
if you look closely at the cross section
of a propeller you'll notice that it
works the same exact way as a wing
as the propeller spins it creates a
forward moving force called thrust
when we're in straight level flight the
angle of attack from the upward moving
propeller and the downward moving
propeller are the same
because of this they both produce the
same amount of thrust
when we pitch the nose of our airplane
up the downward moving propeller which
is the one on the right side of most
airplanes
will have a higher angle of attack this
will make that downward moving propeller
have more thrust
this will make our airplane yaw to the
left
in other words when we pitch the
airplane up that downward moving
propeller takes a bigger bite out of the
air
that bigger bike causes the airplane to
yaw to the left
so the thing to remember about p factor
is that it's strongest at high
angles of attack now let's take a look
at the corkscrew effect
this occurs when the propeller is moving
very fast and the airplane's moving slow
as the propeller spins to create thrust
some of the wind spirals around the
airplane
it's called the spiraling slipstream
as this air corps screws around the
airplane it eventually hits the left
side of the vertical fin
this causes the airplane to yaw to the
left the force on the left side of the
fin
also creates a right rolling moment but
this is mostly offset by the torque
effect
when we increase our air speed the
slipstream gets longer
then at some point it's long enough to
where it no longer hits the tail
so because of that you can see that
corkscrew effect is the greatest at slow
air speeds and high power settings
now let's take a quick look at something
that's not necessarily a left turning
tendency but it kind of falls in this
category
it's gyroscopic precession the propeller
turns
it acts somewhat like a gyroscope
anytime an outside force acts on a
gyroscope
it's subject to a resultant force known
as precession
this force acts 90 degrees ahead of the
applied force
for example if we push our gyroscope up
and it's turning to the right
we'll get a resultant force that moves
the gyroscope to the right
like the gyroscope in the picture our
airplane's propeller turns to the right
so if we move the nose of our airplane
we'll get a resultant force
90 degrees ahead of that movement an
example of this is if we pitch the nose
of our airplane up
and our propellers moving to the right
like we mentioned then we'll get a
resultant force that pushes the nose of
our airplane to the right too
now i know at this point you guys are
thinking big deal this is offset by the
left turning tendencies
but what you might not have considered
is that this can be a pretty big factor
in tailwheel airplanes
because initially they need to pitch
down on takeoff to get the tail wheel
off the ground
when they do this this is basically a
left turning tendency for them too
so now you can kind of see why we
discussed this in this lesson
so the big takeaways in this lesson are
to remember the left turning tendencies
torque effect p factor and corkscrew
effect
these are strongest at high angles of
attack high power
and low air speed also
remember anytime we pitch or yaw the
airplane we're subject to gyroscopic
precession
but it's particularly important in
tailwheel airplanes
hey thanks for joining me today on the
free pilot training channel
if you enjoyed this video today please
smash that like button for me
if you didn't i don't mind the dislike
smash just let me know
why you didn't like it as always don't
forget to subscribe and hit that bell
notification so you know when there's
more free
pilot training